strikes next week what's the impact
going to be well I think it's a real
shame that we're having to call strike
action again because the government's
offer which was five percent and fifteen
hundred pounds was nothing to that began
to even restore the pay erosion and in
fact would have led to another
real-time's pay cut so unfortunately
we've had to call for another three days
of strike action and I'm afraid that
there will be some disruption in
elective and outpatient care for
patients which I don't think anyone in
this country can afford so I don't
understand why the government won't come
back to the table and won't put a
credible offer to the table I want to
talk about what a creditable offer would
look like in a moment but just to sort
of talk in a minute about the impact on
patients you know we're looking at some
of the hospital plans the strikes and
you know you often see statements like
this one from Kings College Hospital in
London you know to help us safely manage
the impact of the strikes we've taken
the decision to postpone the vast
majority of non-urgent appointments and
procedures
in a non-urgent makes it sound not so
bad but you know these people might be
waiting months years even for procedures
would you like to apologize to them well
I think you'd make a really good point
there in that when you when um Hospital
leaders say non-urgent non-urgent might
be something like non-cancer but it's
still really important to each
individual patient who has been waiting
so would you apologize to them often
waiting for a really long time I think
what's really important is that the
government has failed for over a decade
now to produce a credible Workforce plan
that's going to be able to address
outpatient waiting times and we've seen
over the last 10 years waiting times for
appointments go up and up and up it's
the government's responsibility to fund
and resource a healthcare system that
works for everyone in this country I
think a lot of people would agree with
that including people who aren't being
impacted by these strikes
but why don't you just apologize to the
people who as you say will be impacted
by the strikes next week the strikes
don't have to go ahead though to the
table and the government can give us a
credible offer I will I promise I will
talk to you about a credible payoff over
but would you would you like to
apologize to the people or is that not
something you're happy to do I I can
understand that there's going to be an
immense amount of frustration from
patients and from our other colleagues
when our when our doctors go on strike
this weekend and it's going to cause an
immense source of frustration for
everyone
myself my family we all rely on the NHS
as well and the disruption caused is not
pleasant for anyone involved it's a
disaster and it's a disaster that falls
primarily at the feet of government okay
okay understood uh now what is the
current state of play then when it comes
to talks well the government actually
they obliterated any sense of good faith
in those negotiations when they came out
of an offer of five percent and fifteen
hundred pounds this is an offer that's
been tabled to all public sector pay
work all public sector workers and it
just goes to show that Rishi sunak who's
the man who's leading this decree
doesn't recognize the detail and Nuance
of each individual industry he wants to
treat us all with a blunt instrument of
the same payoffer and it doesn't
recognize the extreme pressures that
doctors are under and the extreme pay
erosion that doctors have suffered over
the last 15 years you say that you know
everyone's got this offer and you make
the argument that actually it's a blunt
instrument that there are specific
things about Junior doctors but I guess
the counter argument would be why are
you different from other people in the
public sector many of them including
people who work the NHS who have
accepted the offer on the table
so doctors have suffered now a 31.7 pay
erosion it's increased because Rishi
sunak failed to deliver on keeping
inflation down over the year 22-23 and
doctors have suffered for so long
because we've been operating on a system
of Good Will working under intense
pressures in the NHS not just during the
pandemic but before and I think it's
really
frankly wrong for this government to
continue offering real terms pay cuts
even during this dispute which is
fundamentally about pay restoration
you've say you call the stripe because
the government's failed to make a
credible payoffer I guess the government
would say you've also failed to make a
credible
pay offer as well if you like you know
originally you said you wanted a 35
increase some would say that is just
never going to happen what would you
accept so our paid demand is for full
pay restoration so that no doctor is
worth less now than they were in 2008
because we've sustained 15 years of
paper so what would that mean then in
simple terms what what payers are you
looking for something that reverses our
uh our pay erosion for the last time so
what is that then what is that number is
that 35 well it depends depending on how
many years we want to look over it and
that's something that we're interested
in discussing with the government in
order to make the one-off cost look
smaller can I notice I'm just trying I'm
just trying to I'm just trying to get to
the simple kind of headline here forgive
me for being slightly Bamboozled by the
figures but but what what is that
roughly I mean are you talking
10 are you talking 35 what would that
look like well it depends how many years
we want to look over okay so how many
years do you want to look over then what
would it be well we're happy to look
over a range of years but we need to be
working with governments to understand
where their headspace is and what they
think is Affordable now I think when
they say fair and reasonable then
they're not being fair and reasonable a
real terms pay cut this year is further
pay erosion
pay rise be fair and reasonable no it
wasn't because more than 10 we would yes
because our pay erosion has been 31.7
now over 15 years so you want more than
30 pay rise we would need to structure
it over a series of years and that's
something that we'd be happy to do but I
noticed in one of your previous
interviews you yourself even describes
one billion pounds as a rounding error
uh yeah this was talking about the
puppy was talking about
a 28 billion pounds at Green investment
for example so if you were looking at a
labor government which we could very
well be seeing would you be happy then
if they wouldn't give you a 35 pay rise
but they'd be willing to spend 28
billion pounds on growing investment is
that what you're saying so our
priorities here are to represent doctors
and to be able to restore the payrolls
that doctors have seen because as you
said at the beginning of of our
interview waiting times for appointments
are astronomically high it's not fair or
reasonable for patients to be waiting
two years for outpatient elective
activity and we can only do we can only
fix that issue if we fix the workforce
crisis
on this day you announce that you're
rebaloting members to extend your strike
mandate Beyond August so how long could
these strikes go on for well we'll be
rebalancing between the 19th of June and
31st of August that will give us an
extended six months mandates which will
look towards March of 2024 and if we
need to we will rebalance again during
that period to extend our mandate
further so it could you're talking about
the first
deadline being effectively March next
year but that could be extended if you
don't get what you want you're in this
for the Long Haul our members have given
us a clear instruction they would like
us to pursue full pay restoration back
to 2008 and that's what we intend to do
in our representation of our doctors and
our Healthcare System no matter what the
impact is on the NHS and the
non-patients the long-term impact of on
the NHS without a Workforce and without
doctors as they flee to countries like
Canada Australia and New Zealand is that
these waiting lists will increase we
heard from the Royal College of
Radiologists recently that there are
significant delays to Cancer Care all
year round not just in Winter all year
round because of a lack of Workforce
okay thank you very much for being on
the program you've certainly made your
points very strongly this morning thank
you